Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode. Before we begin,
I've just got a little bit of housekeeping
to sort out, and then we'll move on
with today's session. Today's session is a Kubernetes
security lab slash workshop.
Now I would please encourage you to click
subscribe on YouTube and click the bell. This
will get you notifications for all new episodes.
As I explore the cloud native landscape, you
get to do it with me, and we
can all learn together.
We also have a rather active Discord server
available at Rawkode.chat.
If you're not watching live, that is the
best place to come and ask questions, suggest
new episodes, and get involved with the community.
Please feel free to jump in there, say
hello,
and I'll speak to you soon. And lastly,
I wanna thank Equinix Medal. They are my
employer, and they allow me the resources, the
time, and the energy to invest into this
show producing this content. So thank you very
much.
Thank you very much, Equinix Medal. You could
check out Equinix Medal with a $50 code.
Use Rawkode dash live. $50
is roughly around one hundred hours of compute.
Use it as wisely as you wish.
Okay. Now I know nothing about Kubernetes security,
but
but fortunately,
I'm joined by someone who does. Rory McKeon,
a cloud
oh, I forgot. A cloud developer advocate and
security at Aqua Security.
Is that close? Yeah. Cool. Yeah. Yeah. That's
very good. We we went for cloud native
security advocate. We were trying to work out
what we're gonna call this that I do,
and that's what we've come up with. Cloud
native security advocate. Awesome.
So why don't we just quickly start with
you telling us a little bit about you,
and then we'll talk about what we plan
to cover today.
Sure. Yeah. So
I said I'm an Equinix,
a cloud native security advocate. So my role
is basically trying to educate and inform
around around cloud native security, Kubernetes security, containers.
That's why I'm really happy to be doing
this today. I've been doing container security now
for about five years. Started with my previous
role,
and I've been doing a number of things
around that, working with CIS benchmarks, which if
you do not come across, well worth looking
at. But the other thing I did was
I did a training course, and that's where
the lab that we're looking at today came
from.
As part of developing the training course, a
common question from people on it was, how
can I practice this after the course? Now
I thought, that's a good question.
And then thanks to the wonders of
kind, which we'll see, and Ansible, we worked
out actually, it's not too difficult. We can
give you a little lab that you can
work on anytime you like. I actually practice
some, like, attack techniques in a safe place,
right, where you're not potentially attacking someone's thing
that you don't own.
So and that's where this came from.
Awesome.
Well, I must say you have your work
cut out for you today teaching me security
stuff.
No easy task. But I'm looking forward to
playing with this lab and
hopefully not skating myself too much, but, you
know, it might be par for the course
I think with this.
Okay.
I guess we should just share my screen.
We'll give everyone a link to the repository.
We're gonna be using Docker for Mac for
this today. So hopefully that is something that
you can all do at home as you
follow along.
So how how old is this lab? How
long have you been working on it? Two
year I think it's about two years. So
we started doing the training course. The first
time we did it for a conference was
Black Hat twenty eighteen EU.
And, it was like the a couple of
runs after that, people started saying, hey. This
is great, but I want to practice at
home, which I can which you understand because
you do these training courses, and it's a
lot of information in a short space of
time.
So, absolutely, people want to take it away.
And I was at the time, was playing
a bit with with Ansible and then also
getting into kind. So if if people on
the have not used kind already, use kind
is the one that you should take from
today. Kind is awesome.
If you don't have anything with security, take
that because kind makes this work.
Yeah. I guess we could quickly cover what
kind does, and then people will also see
an action as we start to spin up
our first kind of Kubernetes clusters. But kind,
I believe, stands for Kubernetes and Docker and
allows you to have a fully functioning
multi node, which I think is really cool,
Kubernetes cluster running purely in containers.
I think it makes really good for this
kind of thing because you want to,
you know, you want to throw away container.
Right? You don't want to you don't want
these things hanging around because they're deliberately insecure.
You don't want them on the Internet because
they're deliberately insecure.
Having them in a nice isolated kind environment,
I think, really helps.
Yeah. I couldn't agree more.
So what's the format for this? You know?
Do we just need to spin up our
first cluster? Is it gonna get me through
I know I should probably read the documentation,
but I'm always particularly impatient. So so right.
So, essentially, we've got a couple of things
to start with. You scroll yeah. You see
the getting started there. So, essentially, what there
is is
there's a a kind of client machine container.
There's a little container that what you can
use as kind of the client when you're
actually attacking the clusters.
And then what we've got is we've got
a series of different clusters,
each one with a different vulnerability. Right? So
it's gonna be each one has got something
wrong with it, the name the clue is
generally in the name,
and we can kinda go through and attack
each one. But you can do some of
the stuff straight from, like, the Mac, but
it's easier if you kinda go into this
client container because it's got the tools installed,
which is kind of gets rid of why
I don't have a tool to do that
with.
So
yep.
I was just gonna say, I I get
is this teaching, like, best practices in defensive
security by giving people a kind of attackers'
playground? Is that the is that the the
goal?
Yeah. The idea I think is to an
extent,
I think people some of it's quite obvious.
Right? Some of it's gonna be you'll see
something, okay, that you would never do that.
Other ones, it can kind of inform you
of, like, oh, I didn't realize that, for
example, how easy it was to go from
create pods to I control the whole cluster.
So if you got a a developers who've
got create pod access,
we can say, hey. This is how easy
it is to go from there to they
could own the whole cluster anytime they wanted
to.
And I think that kind of, you know,
that's all not always understood. Yeah. Okay. That
makes sense.
Alright. So
the first thing I need to do is
it to run the client machine? Yeah. So
that that that should bring up the client
machine.
So that's This is our acid test for
is is everything working in the prereqs? Should
be.
Oh, we're gonna find out. Okay. Let's see
what happens.
Let's find out.
That's fine.
Actually, yeah, I set this up because I
was having problems with my CI.
Oh, application warning.
Oh,
if you do just a straight create cluster,
I know what that is. That is and
this is the first thing that that that
I forgot. When kind first comes up, it
creates a Docker network for kind.
Ah, right.
And so if you've never run kind on
the machine you're using so usually, of course,
I've run kind for something else.
So I don't hit that, but that will
be
I'm trying to create something. That's that's I
should take notes or something.
Bugs that come up when someone else tries
this because I know what I know I
know what goes wrong when I try it.
I think what threw me off there was
just that really noisy deprecation warning for the
one really sensible error at the end. The
one actually useful error at the bottom but
it's like because
I was like, oh, shit. We're not gonna
be able to fix all that. I don't
it's just that one little thing here which
makes a lot of sense. That's just something
Ansible that changed down the line, actually, probably.
That's on my list of oh, that's gonna
break at some point, but not yet.
Do we have to wait on this kind
cluster? Do you think it's already Probably will
I don't think it'll create the network straight
off. It shouldn't take super long. We got
a preparing note. But it's got there. I'll
put this later finish, I guess. What's the
And you you've got you've got the Mac
terminals. You get the nice pretty graphics.
That's, like, kind of
They're not standard, though? On some terminals on
a lot of terminals, you don't get them.
Like, some of the emojis don't exist. So
you get, well, just little gray boxes or
whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. I guess you gotta have, like,
a font with the glyphs being done or
power line symbols or something like that. That's
it. You've gotta have some kind of and
I I know some of the it's obviously
the Mac that has it, but but some
of the terminals I've used, you have to
go and find a specific font and install
it to get the the shiny graphics.
I run the Cascadia font Cascadia code font
from Microsoft, which ships with the power limbo
power light symbols baked in really cool. Love
that. I mean, I I I think I
spend more time tweaking my terminal, my color
theme, and my fonts than I actually do
any real work.
Mhmm. And I think it's a slippery slope.
I don't know if other developers are like
that or if that's just something that I
waste my time doing. But I've I know
what I do. I I I spent a
whole time
creating like a whole Ansible playbook to set
up my terminal to do all sorts of
stuff.
At least I went to the point of
well, I I did the bike sharing going
and actually automating it.
So let's try that now. Hopefully, that should
now be happier.
Yeah. I'm sure it will be. I've got
nothing but confidence in the sounds of all
people. Yeah. I've got yeah. So it's gonna
complain.
Here's where it complains about the deprecation.
And it's going and pulling the image in
the background.
Think this is
So that's client machine, and then we have
to let's just carry on with the instructions,
I guess. Yeah. So So what we do
is once we go on that, if you
have to scroll down, we can look at
our vulnerable cluster list. So these are the
ones
this kind of thing where you can implement
lots of these. These are essentially all the
different ones, and and this this these these
examples were built essentially from the course. These
are things where we cover this on the
course, so I thought, right. Time to write
a playbook.
And you as you can said, you can
see from the names that that each one
of them's got kind of a descriptive name.
So,
for example, we got unauthenticated a p unauthenticated
API server,
then near the bottom, which is an API
server that has anonymous access possible.
And we've got unauthenticated dashboard. So you'll know
that, like, people like Tesla, some years ago,
in the early days of Kubernetes, they were
using the Kubernetes dashboard and left it on
the Internet without authentication,
and that ended badly for them.
So this is just an example of that.
So Yeah. The Kubernetes dashboard for so long
never shipped with any authentication anyway.
Yeah. Yeah. So so that that one so,
yeah, there's there's there's there's there's various things
that actually work kinda like in the old
days. In the old days of Kubernetes,
we're actually at the defaults. So the kubelet
for a long time I think there's about
three versions the kubelet shipped with no authentication
possible.
So you just you had to know the
port was there, and you could always compromise
the machine, which was fun.
That's actually how I got into Kubernetes security.
I I literally started looking at it. It
was 2018,
and
and someone said said to me they sent
me a link and said, this is possible.
I said, no. That can't be right. I
didn't believe that. And I was like, oh,
that works. And then I went and found
the GitHub issue, and it did work for,
like, three versions.
Wow.
So,
hopefully yeah. So what we're gonna do is
once we've once the client machine's up, we
can just pick one of these.
What should we do to start with? So
these are This is simple. All Ansible products.
Right? I can just run Ansible against any
of these. It's gonna create a new cluster
with that vulnerability.
With that on it. Probably
the insecure port is, like, the easiest. Okay.
So it's it's happy now. Yeah.
So the insecure port is probably the most
simple.
Okay. This is gonna give me a client
cluster running Kubernetes with no authentication. Or no.
It's gonna be using the because that's a
real Yeah. Insecure port we're running. Yeah. The
old parameter insecure port was, I think, only
got deprecated in 01/20,
I want to say. Yeah. That was It
was surprisingly recent. It was recent. Okay. Ansible
and secure
So it's Ansible the Ansible dash playbook.
I'm sure there's I'm sure there's docs there.
If if if it's just it's just the
same command as it's ansible dash playbook and
then that that file should do it.
Yeah. And then the insecure. Yeah.
So that should do.
Okay. So how do I test that my
hacker tools are working?
So what we can do is once we've
once this has come up, we can just
docker exec into that client container,
and that will be that's got all the
tools and everything. And it should be on
and it's on the same network, so we
don't have worry about anything about what Docker
for Mac is doing in terms of with
network weirdness, which is kinda why I did
this because Docker for Mac and Docker for
Windows use some very clever but moderately complicated
things
with networking. And and I just thought that's
going to cause
things to fail in kind of odd ways.
So it's easier if we just have a
client machine on the same network as the
the target cluster.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense.
I guess we'll just give this a a
few seconds. So all those Yeah. So this
stuff should be cached. Right? It's Yeah. Once
once they come down, once they're cached. And
what I did was I've
I kind of, like, created custom kind so
kind of a node image, and I've just
customized that. And because,
I guess, as versions go on, they'll stop
supporting the old broken stuff. So as things
get better mean, to be fair, I'm seeing
about kind of things that were really bad
for security in Kubernetes history. They are going
away, you know, one at a time. You
know, insecure port is going Kubel always needs
authentication now. So things are improving, so I'm
kind of trying to keep the old stuff
so we can kind of demonstrate still demonstrate
these things because a lot of companies still
do run older clusters. You know, companies do
not always move on to the new shiny
that quickly.
Well, yeah. I think it was just yesterday.
The Kubernetes project announced they were slowing down
the release cadence, just three releases a year
to try and help organizations.
You know, four is is a big ask
for some organization to upgrade their production clusters
four times per year.
Yeah. So, I mean, I one of the
one of the the things I always said
at every I think every talk I've done
and definitely the training for enterprise customers is
you do realize this thing will need upgraded
every single year. So I used to work
for large UK banks, and I know that
is not their way.
That is not the way they do things.
They don't upgrade whole systems every year.
So so having a new thing that, you
know, you're gonna have to upgrade every year
is going to be a bit of a
kinda culture shock, I think, in some cases.
And even even enterprise things like OpenShift now,
they they've got the same release the same
support life cycle as Kubernetes. They used to
have, like, a really long one, but not
anymore.
Yeah. I remember, you know, back when you
used your groups there a thing, I used
to speak to people that worked at banks.
They would always tell me that, you know,
it's not a job for everyone because you
have to get comfortable writing a line of
code and then waiting six months for that
to hit production.
Yeah. That's the Yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of the banks are running systems
that have been there
literally since, like, the seventies and eighties,
and they're still running the bank. And their
big problem now is that the people who
write who manage them are all retiring.
So if you ever want a really stable
job, learn how to code COBOL on mainframes
and go work for a bank, and you
will never be redundant.
Which is not great, Cobalt. Decided to bake
my feet, so I fired.
There you see. I've
evicted our cat because otherwise, he would have
made his presence known.
So
so now we should be up and running,
and it looks so our client so our
our server tells you there at the bottom.
The last thing it's doing is printing it
saying the target IP address of our, you
know, vulnerable cluster is of that.
So we can now docker exec
into the client machine.
Is it just called client machine? Yeah. So
minus IT client machine
and then bin bash should work.
Where's the name?
Oh, just go client. Sorry. Oh, client. Yeah.
Consistent
naming, I never get it right. So now
so now we're in our client, and we
now have access to the same network as
our target. We know that our target server
has got is on my IP address.
So for this one, this one should be
really fairly straightforward.
We can check first thing you would do
if you were actually attacking a cluster or
if you're looking at machine, you'd probably port
scan it. Right? So you you'd say, okay.
I want to know what services are there
for me to attack.
And in the lab client, we've got nMap
installed, which is kinda like the usual port
scanner.
So if if you just nMap should be
installed there.
K. Yeah. So if we do
nMap minus small s, then capital t,
minus v,
minus n,
then just the IP address.
It should
there we go. And you can see we've
got port eighty eighty o,
which is our insecure server
insecure port.
And so now we know we've got access
to that. So if we were, you know,
looking at this machine, we go, okay. It's
port if if we got an idea that
it's Kubernetes server, we know, okay. This is,
this is what we're probably going to want
to attack. And so then we need to
actually tell kubectl this where you get you
you see how your memory for kubectl,
flags is.
Okay.
And I and I'll I'll what I'll do
is I'll mention actually actually a pretty important
point for the repository.
In the in the GitHub repository,
there's two folders.
If you scroll, there's one called scenario setups
and one called scenario walkthroughs.
So the scenario setups is just like how
you get it running because there's a couple
that have a bit more to do. And
then in scenario walkthroughs, there's kinda like the
cheat sheet. Alright. Okay. So so if we
get stuck and and I I probably would
remember all the things to do with these,
we can always go in there and it
remind us.
So for this one, it should be super
simple.
So this one should be, like, awesomely simple.
We just do
kubectl
minus s
and then HTTP
and then the IP address, 8080, and then
anything.
Yeah.
And
oh.
Oh, here we go. That's come back. And
we're okay. Yeah. So was gonna thought before.
Yep. So we got access. Now this is
the thing with the insecure API port for
people who might not have encountered it is
it's an old thing, and it allowed
completely
cluster admin access. Right? If you get access
to that, it's cluster admin. You are cluster
admin.
This was still in use in the default
install of some Kubernetes distributions until, like, a
couple of versions ago.
So it's not amazingly unlikely you might find
this. And we have when I used to
be a pen tester in my previous role,
we did find clusters that had this running.
People would use it for, like, monitoring. So
they'd say, okay. I I can't be bothered,
like, configuring,
like, rules and and creds for monitoring services.
I'll just use the insecure support.
I'd like that never happened, but it did.
I I'm definitely guilty of throwing my monitor
in the end secure port. But I don't
know if I was being really naive or
just misunderstood, but I also thought it was
read only. I'm assuming it's not. No. It's
totally close. It's cluster admin. If you get
in secure port, that's it. It's game over.
Of course. Your entire cluster is yeah. It
well, this is one of the problems is
that
not super well known, and it's not always
super well documented, some of the stuff. I
mean, actually, that's not that's not fair. The
Kubernetes documents like documentation site is amazing. Knowing
where to look to find everything can be
a challenge if you don't know. So if
you don't know that that's a problem, you
don't know to go looking for it.
So
in terms of, like, the way the lab
is structured,
what I set up is, like, the target,
and it's in in the read me. It
says, the target for every attack is to
try and get the certificate authority private key
from the the the cluster master.
And and the idea for that is that
that's the golden key. Right? If you ever
get that on a real Kubernetes cluster,
you've got persistent backdoor access to the cluster
for the lifetime of that key, which is
usually measured in years.
So if you ever give someone read access
to that file, that's your cluster is theirs
for as long as they want it,
until that key expires. And most clusters I've
seen installed will go somewhere between two and
ten years.
So, realistically, the life of the cluster.
Oopsie. So, yeah, that's this is a a
fun this
is, like, my big one of my big
things, again, people should know about your security
is protecting that file. Like, read access to
that file is super, super sensitive.
So I'm assuming then that with this secure
port enabled, I can just create a pod
spec with a host path mode for slash,
let's say, Kubernetes PKI and then everything I
need is sitting there. Yeah. We can And
so the fun Probably
the easiest way of doing this one is
you can actually because it's QBADM
that runs all the clusters,
the control plane components run as pods,
so you can just exec into them. Of
course they can. Yeah. So
what we can do is if we
there's no there's no yeah. Oh,
yeah. My dash s. Okay. Yeah. I
should really just export those but I don't
think I'll be in this cluster too long.
Oh, nice to be s. Yep.
It
will be for all the other ones also.
So you're saying I could just jump into
the API Yeah. I'm in the API server.
There won't be a binary there, will there,
Shell?
Bing Shell? Probably Bing Shell, I reckon will
work.
Trash.
Try Bing Shell. I wonder if Bing Shell
will work.
I thought Bing Shell.
Yeah. They all seem to be they also
I think, I mean, those there's some plans
to not. So in, yeah, in PKI
And there we go. That's the c a
key. So yeah. So if if you literally
read access to that key is and that's,
a big thing
that that people should know about running Kubernetes
is be awesomely careful with that key.
Because if you give someone This one? Yeah.
The the reason why you need to be
so careful is if someone can read that
key, they can create a new client certificate
and
sign it. We think that we're using that
key to sign. And because client certificate authentication
is always turned on in Kubernetes and you
can't turn it off,
You can create a a credential. Just say,
want this credential to last for five years,
and I want it to be member of
group system masters,
which is cluster admin access.
So if anyone ever reads that key,
it's yeah.
So that's why.
I guess from a,
like, a defensive point of view, like, if
you've got a you'd want to have your
audit controller log stuff like this as well.
Right? Is that is that possible?
You can you can put
yes. Yeah. You can definitely do things like,
for example,
tools like Falco, I'm guessing, or other runtime
security tools.
So there's a variety of those. Tracy is
there as well. We can alert on you
doing things like exacting shells and containers.
So if you exact a shell into a
container, then you're going to you're gonna get
you're gonna get caught.
I think, for me, probably the hardest part,
though, is if people want to do, like,
backups of their clusters. I've never seen a
great idea for you know, you're gonna want
to back these files up because you need
them, but you have to be really careful
where you back them up.
And I have seen I've seen at least
one distribution that actually
puts them in a config map.
Oh, wow.
I was gonna suggest, like, a public accidentally
public SD bucket, which I've seen before as
well. That will I have also seen
again, when I used to do pentest of
clusters, I have seen people check them into
GitHub. Private repositories, obviously, but still checked into
GitHub. But, of course, then you don't know
who's cloned it. Right? So someone's cloned it.
You have no idea what they've done with
it once they've cloned it. Then they leave
the company. They move team.
Yeah. Yeah. Because
the only way to fix that is rotate
everything.
Okay.
We got a question. You happy to take
questions as we go? Yeah. Yeah. Questions are
absolutely fine.
Noel was asking, you said the docs are
extensive.
Are all of the exercises that we're gonna
do in this repository doc?
Are they mentioned are the docs mentioned, I
guess, in the the lab?
Yeah. So in the setup and walk throughs,
I think I've got walk throughs for every
single one apart from two. There's two that
aren't done yet. But so so everyone we
do today, definitely, the walk throughs will be
in that folder.
Okay. Perfect. And Cool. A random comment from
who's asking if we can show how to
install Rancher.
I'm afraid not, but there is a video
on the YouTube channel. Please feel free to
go check that out. Alright. I do Rancher.
I have done rancher. I like rancher. Rancher's
really cool. It's actually a different episode, actually.
The jukebox episode where I just kinda stream
and say, right, what what are we doing?
Let the audience Yeah.
I was I was a great fan of
the of TGIK.
Yes. And they do that sometimes where they
will say, let's try this. I haven't done
it before. And and that you you you
tend to find some fun stuff there. Oh,
definitely.
Okay. So that's our first one. Right? So
we've we've got the kind of concept now.
Have cluster, attack cluster,
find the key file.
Okay. Should we do another one? I would
love to. Should I start shutting stuff down?
Is that important? Yeah. You you if you
just if you exit that, then I it
just if you shut down the
if you you can get clusters,
and it'll tell you the name and then
just shut down the insecure board one.
Shut it down or kill it? I'll just
delete it. Minus minus name I think it
needs. Yeah. It's like minus minus name for
the
Alright.
Depends on I think it one of the
problems I've got these is my machine is
so powerful. I end up leaving these running
and I come back and I got like
10 kind clusters.
Yeah. I'm I'm not sure my Mac software
running the streaming software and Yeah.
At least my fans are probably all I've
got headphones on, I'm not sure. But I'm
pretty sure my fans are already going mental.
So Yeah.
I I went the whole desktop route now
and now it's like a four gig RAM.
You just don't notice. I left an OpenShift
cluster running and didn't notice, which is impressive.
That is pretty good. I like that.
Okay. So Well, I have to pick one.
Do you wanna pick one? Should we should
we do kubelet? Kubelet's so there's one there
r w kubelet no auth. Yep. I I
I kinda like that one because, again,
the the the the kubelet has its own
HTTP API,
but
go try finding documentation on it.
It's one place where there's not you can
go read the code,
but it there's not, like so because it's
not intended for external use, but it does
have one. So we can we can have
a look with that. That's that's quite a
fun one. Yeah. Okay. So that means I
have to run Ansible playbook, pass in this,
and let it spin up our new cluster.
Yeah. So and it should be faster this
time because it's gonna have the image, I
think.
We'll see. So I actually wasn't aware that
the kubelet had an API. Why? Yeah. What's
the intended use? Do we know? It's the
API server talking to the Kubelet.
So the API server has to tell the
Kubelet to tell the CRI to go do
stuff.
Yes. And it's this API and it's actually
it's an interesting one because it's one of
the places where
the TLS configuration of, like, QBIDM clusters is
not perfect out of the box.
It uses a self signed certificate. So, usually,
that's, like, signed in the certificate authority. But
for when the API server's talking to the
Kubelet,
the certificate is by default just self signed.
So there's a risk of, like, man in
the middle and stuff.
So the ship the Kubelet doesn't subscribe with
a watch then, like, all the other component?
It goes that way. But if the but
the API server, somebody seems to go the
other way and say, hey, mister Kubel, go
and do stuff. I think that's my understanding
of it. I will accept corrections on that
point though, for sure.
Alright. Okay. Well, you know, I I love
to learn on these things. So that's something
I had no idea about, which is cool.
Yeah. But now we're gonna take advantage of
it, I guess. We're yeah. We're gonna show
how you can take advantage of it. And
this this one's this one's a little bit
fun because we we're gonna do all our
hacking for this one with curl.
Curl.
Okay.
I I know a few curl flags.
I yeah. That's one of the fun things
I one of the reasons I like
I'm a great fan of HTTP APIs,
and and I also get annoyed when things
go gRPC from a attacker's perspective. HTTPs are
so many tools. You know, you can just
use anything which
which talks that. And and then with gRPC,
it's into, like, what proto do you have
and do you have all the other things?
I guess even with issue two p, if
the only tool you had was Telnet, you
could probably still make that work. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. But you're always gonna have Carol.
Yeah.
The Carol author on Twitter always posts, like,
messages about the release and the Carol birthday
and and all the new contributors and stuff.
And just the sheer age and size of
that project always amazes me. Yeah. I think
it's 23
years old this year, like, this month it
was.
Yeah. It's been going such a long I
he's got some really great information about things
like
how all the different weird things you can
put in URLs.
So people are ever thinking of doing, like,
regex on HTTP URLs, be really careful.
It's it's astonishing
the weird stuff you can put in URLs
and how it's not part of a spec.
So you can say I'm spec compliant, and
it still will do something odd.
That's great fun.
Alright.
Okay. So I'm gonna copy this IP address.
I'm gonna assuming I'm going back into my
Docker, my client.
Yeah. That's the one.
And,
I mean, in theory, I could just run
the same command to see if things are
running. Right? But I'm assuming that's not Yeah.
So this should fail horribly. It should say,
no. I'm gonna I'm not yeah. I'm not
gonna play ball with that. Okay.
But if we do if we do the
actually, if you go up, we should look
at nmap. Actually, I don't know. Or just
retype that, actually. We can do nmap again,
we can show that the
Oh, it might not oh, it might not
know the port. If you give it minus
p,
just before the IP address,
and then do minus p 10250,
Let's see if hopefully, it should find it.
Yes. Is that is that not the read
only port, actually? That that that's read write.
So read only is 10255.
5 5 o. That was deprecated, wasn't it?
Yeah. I was gonna say that's gone because
that was again, it was one of the
early ones and and it was could not
authenticate the read read only port. There was
no option to do it. So it was
it was great information disclosure. If you're a
pen tester, hit that port, and you get
quite a lot of kinda useful information, definitely
starting points.
I in the early days, there was cAdvisor
as well on four one nine four, but
that that went. I think it went a
lower in the browser.
Yeah. The the one zero two five five
is actually the the read only port I
use for monitoring. So now I feel less
guilty that I wasn't
I I am I'm happy that I wasn't
using the API servers
and secure ones. Yeah.
Oh, the API server and secure ones. Yeah.
Well, you've seen that's that's how yeah. The
the read only
keyboard port is not terrible.
It's not I mean, as a pen tester,
I liked it. I I, you know, I
was I was always happy when I saw
it. But it wasn't like a game over.
It wasn't I I would have finished my
job today and that's me done. Yeah. You
have all the information that you need. Right?
Almost? Yeah. But each host?
Yeah. It tells you things like, you know,
what images am I running? What flags is
the API server running? If you had control
plane node? Lots of cool stuff that might
otherwise lead you, you know
but, yeah, it's not game over. But this
is this is the read write one. So
this is this is the one with the
with the funky API.
So to testing that, what we can do
just to get started, if you curl minus
k because it's gonna be HTTPS.
And, yeah, it's HTTPS
on that. And then
And you should get four zero four. Right?
So that that's fine. The the base URL
says, no. Go away. I'm not I'm not
want but but because it's given us something,
we know it's running, and we know it's
not authenticated.
Because if it was authenticated at this point,
it would say, no. Go away. You haven't
given me the client certificate I was expecting.
So from attacker's perspective, just seeing that 404
is, like, that's okay. I've got something to
look at here.
So then you need to know then you
need to know the
the end end points. And then the first
one is pods.
Nice and simple.
And,
yeah, Jake is there
for that reason
because otherwise, you're there forever. So now we
we we know every pod that this kubelet
is is running on the machine. Every pod,
every security context,
every volume amount,
everything. And this is kinda what you got
out of the read only port.
So it is actually kind of
it's kinda gives you an idea of the
level of information disclosure.
But what we need to do now, and
this is this is the fun part. We
might need a text file to, like, copy
paste bits and pieces,
is all the information we need
to get access to
that key
is in the information we just got. Because
there's an endpoint on the kubelet API called
run,
and it lets you run commands inside pods.
But we need some bits of information to
make it work.
Okay. Let's get that text Yeah. Open.
Documents.
I will you don't need to see it.
Right? I can just leave it off screen.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So the first thing we
need is namespace. Now that's always gonna be
cube system because we wanna try and get
the API server pod. So if we do
the endpoint is is run,
and then it's gonna be slash. And the
next thing you put after this after slash
after slash, then it's cube system.
Then what we need to know is we
need to know the pod name.
And so the pod name, we're gonna scroll
up until we see if can find the
API server pod in that output.
It will be there somewhere, but it might
be a way up. Let's hope the scroll
back buffer doesn't Oh, my god. Was there
from pods.
Correct.
Okay.
Network. Oh.
Wonder whether Why does the network?
Is it is it API test server or
Yeah.
Correct.
Okay.
That's it for API probably wasn't my best
move, but we we are we do have
it kinda restricted. I wonder if we can
find out the where is it going to
be?
Yeah. There we go. So that's that named
cube dash API server dash.
That'll be that one there, I think. Yeah.
Think that's pointing the screen that you guys
are pointing.
I pasted that into my thingy. Okay. Yeah.
So you got that.
So we
have that,
and then after that
so, yeah, paste that in and then slash,
and then the name of the container, is
always kubit dash API server.
That one's pretty simple.
We've got a nice case. So now we
need to tell it so the way this
API works is you're posting. So you post
the command you want it to run.
So we do minus capital x post.
Mhmm. Yeah. And
at the end of it all, we want
minus lowercase d
and then space,
open quotes,
c m d
equals let's do who am I to be
to start with. Let's see if that's gonna
work.
Yay.
I think Noel has maybe done this lab
before. Otherwise, he's just been doing bad things
to other people's kubelets, but I kind of
suggested that.
I can add there. Okay.
I have
the ability to run any command as you
were inside the kubel API.
Yeah. So this is this is why leaving
the Kubel open is really dangerous
because, basically, you are essentially, Kubel controls Docker.
So you think about I've got Docker exec,
that's what you've got, essentially. You've got anything
you can do with Docker.
Yeah. I see it up here.
And that's backdoor access to the cluster. So
anyone leaving the kubelet open and there have
been cases. So, like,
Aqua have a research team who have honeypots,
and they look for people scanning the Internet.
And one of the things that the the
crypto coin mining community
have worked out is that cubelets allow you
to execute code and execute commands on machines.
So they absolutely do look for these.
And if you leave so if anyone ever
left a cubelet port open on the Internet,
you can basically expect someone to do that
quite simply.
But that that that vulnerability was actually that
was the thing that got me to Kubernetes
security. So that was in 2018.
That was that always worked. That worked on
every cluster. And, like, for about probably the
first couple of Kubernetes security reviews I did,
that was my oh, look. My cluster.
Well, that's eye opening. This is at least,
like
It's a it's a fun one. I like
that one.
It's So it's not a well documented API.
So simple as well. Just Yeah. A quick
curl command. As a fact that I understand
why the kubelet run API endpoint is there,
but just super dangerous.
But that's just now authenticated only. Right? That's
what you were saying. That's that's how Yeah.
So it it by default,
obviously, you can turn that off. Right? So
it is it is possible if you misconfigure
the Kubelet or if someone tries to do
something with Kubelet that they could make a
mistake.
And it's kind of a good reason why
it's worth,
like, periodically having these things these these tools,
like, Kube Hunter and some other tools, which
will, like, probe these. There's also CyberArk. I've
got a tool called Kubelet Cuddle,
which will automate that process. So instead of
using curl, they actually have a tool, a
Go binary. You run the Go binary against
that API, and it does all this for
you,
which is really super neat.
So, yeah, it's worth kinda doing those periodically
on your clusters. You should just get back
nothing. Right? You should create, nope. You're not
authenticated.
Go away.
Okay.
We have a comment say in our use
of the word crypto community. It was maybe
a little bit harsh. I don't think it
was intended to be Crypto mining. Crypto mining.
Oh, I said crypto mining community. Sorry. I
understand. Yeah. I I mean, crypto I said
crypto mining community. Sorry. Maybe I wasn't I
wasn't clear. My accent might not have crypto.
No. I wouldn't say crypto community, but crypto
mining community.
The people who go around, compromising people's machines
for crypto mining for clarity. Yeah. I I
I know what you mean. There are a
lot of people out there that are scripting
all of these weird and wacky ways to
be able to run crypto miners on any
sort of computer across the entire Internet. We
mean those people.
Yeah. Those people. The people who are yeah.
So for clarity, the people who are doing
that look for cubelets because they provide compute
in the same way as the API server
provides compute or the Docker socket provides compute.
It I mean, that port number, I guess,
you find that open anywhere, you're it's pretty
much just a a green flag. You know
right away you can probably get access to
it. Yeah. It yeah. Unlike eighty eighty can
be a bit you know, a lot of
things use the eighty eighty because it's, the
alternate web port. But the Kubelet port, one
zero two five o, that's there's not a
lot of other things. So yeah.
And there are scanning
services that will hit that now. So I'm
pretty sure Binary Edge, which is another similar
thing to Shodan,
it will it it indexes one zero two
five o.
So I should I should run it on
port one zero two five one then. So
up here. Yay.
Absolutely.
Actually, no. There's something that runs on one
zero two five one. Weirdly,
all of the components like scheduler and controller
manager run on ports, generally just for health
check.
They only look at health zed end point,
but you you find there's loads of ports
now.
But, yeah, you could run a different port,
obviously, authentication.
Yeah. Just keep that turned on. Don't turn
off. Don't turn off. Don't ever break it.
So
I'm gonna have to get the list again.
You know, I'll I'll leave it running till
my computer start crying, and then maybe I'll
start shutting down. Yeah. Let's start spinning up
the next one at least first. So we've
done n secure with a read write, kubelet.
That was a scary one.
Do we want to do
a kind of a user one or do
want to do an x c d? X
c d is like the other one for,
like, server stuff.
It's like the other like, obviously, the database
where things are, or you wanna do an
SSH to things one. Well, I I guess
the attack factor with x e d is,
like, I if I put something into x
e d, like, the compute the API server
is gonna make that run somewhere. Is that
the attack factor there, or is it something
else? So
if you allow the if if you either
get creds for the etcd server or if
someone puts etcd unauthenticated
so, for example, they turn off it'll put
authentication properly on etcd,
then, obviously, you can dump out anything's in
etcd.
So it's a question of how do you
go from iPhone port twenty three seventy nine,
which is the XCD port,
to running code on the cluster?
And and there's a couple of steps to
that, which are kind of fun. We we
can if you want, we can look at
that. That's the last of the big server
port attacks. Yeah. Why not? Let's do it.
So we do have a question, which I'll
get to in a second, but we'll spend
this one up first.
Let that run. Okay.
Noel is back with a question.
Are any of these vulnerabilities that we are
looking at or or part of the labs
still shut by QBADM by default?
No.
QBADM QBADM,
I've done a lot of work. And and
this great props to the QBADM team. They've
done a lot of work on, like, the
defaults so that this doesn't because, obviously, this
would be super dangerous if if if this
is allowed by default.
I would say that all the major distributions
now
get this right.
If you'd asked me that question two years
ago, I would not be saying the same
thing.
But now,
it's it's it's it's getting a lot better.
That said, you know, the there are, like,
a 20,
I think, certified distributions.
Do all of them get all of these
right all the time is a good question.
And if someone has a load of time
on their hands,
you could totally go and find out probably,
but you'd have to have a lot of
time in your hands.
So,
I mean, I guess, it's q QPDM just
must be the best way for people to
go. Like, if they're not going down to
OpenShift or any other distribution Yeah. Like, people
shouldn't be manually configuring all of this themselves.
They should just Yeah. Use QPDM.
Right? I I would say that. Yeah. I
I I QPDM,
there's a lot of,
like, weird edge cases that you don't know.
Actually, ETCD is a good one. So the
way ETCD works
with its authentication
is it trusts
any certificate issued by the certificate authority it's
been told to trust.
So you have to have different certificate authorities,
one for XCD and one for Kubernetes. You
can't use the same one, or anyone with
a client cert for Kubernetes would be able
to get to XCD.
And SCD has no authorization, so it just
gives everything to anyone
in the way that Kubernetes sets it up.
So it's that's a that's a kind of
a weird edge case. You wouldn't have thought
of that. I wouldn't have thought of that.
But
knowing that, yeah, that's the sort of thing
that could be a DM have done the
work. They've they've worked out what's needed and
done the hard work to do that.
Oh, yeah. I can imagine, like, you know,
certificate authority and certificate management is a pain
in the ass the best of times. If
I was hand rolling my own Kubernetes clusters,
it makes it insensible to just say, hey.
I'm gonna have one CA. I'm gonna provision
and send a bunch of certificates and not
really think beyond that. But then when you
realize that, oh, anything why am I clustered
now has the ability to speak to the
database that powers it.
That's And I've I've seen I've seen distributions
made that mistake. I've absolutely seen distributions made
that mistake because it's not something that's well
known. You know, if you don't know that,
and it's and it's not obvious. And the
thing is what I find with what in
my kind of I'm I'm just a security
person, but from from what I've seen of
how people use Kubernetes,
it's a big complicated system. When you take
out the box, you use it as provided.
You don't go playing with it because you
want it to work.
Yeah. That's
true.
Okay. Let's see.
Oh, it's still spinning. Okay. It's still spinning?
Maybe your laptop's fans are actually, it should
be kinda is quite nice and light. It's
it's Oh, yeah. They're they're taken off. Maybe
I should have cut the other one.
Alright. It's
it's got past the hard part.
We could still shut that down.
So delete cluster
name and that was a redrary.
Yeah.
Okay.
I would have laughed if I shut down
s t d no off, but I'm okay.
Yeah.
Alright. So we have our IP and I'm
gonna jump back into our
oh, client machine. There we go.
Are we we end mapping?
No. We can yep. We can end map.
We can end map for Port 2379.
That should be our our port of choice
here.
Oh, it's 0 5. It is one up.
Shut the other one down, it's it's last
digits five.
Very good. Cool.
And it oh, nMap knows it's nMap knows
about that port now. Because that service line
just comes from nMap's database. Yeah.
So it must have, like, decided it knows
what SCD is now, which is cool.
Making hacker's lives easier everywhere. Yeah.
You know, you gotta use mMap. I it
shows you that I spent a large number
of years using nmap that I've got because
I can remember all this. The one it's
the one command I don't forget the flags
on. Everything else, I'll have to look up.
But nmap, I'm fine. No. Nmap and TCP
tumper tools I reached to as a very,
very last resort. So they're definitely not something
I'm comfortable with.
Yeah.
So what we're gonna do so obviously, etcd
is gRPC. It's not HTTP. Although,
there is an HTTP API in there. It's
just a bit hidden.
Should do the job.
And the first thing we need to do
is the really weird thing that I always
forget,
which is need to export an environment variable
to tell it we're using version three. Yes.
So it's export
alright. So export. X c d c t
l
underscore API equals three.
Yeah. I have a Otherwise cheat sheet that
I always use to configure s c d
Yeah. When on clustered especially just because I
could never remember those
that Yeah. The temptation to get it working.
I never remember that and I always wonder
why it doesn't work. And then I go
after about three or four tries, oh, that.
So now it's like one of those things
I think I've done enough that burned into
my brain.
So we should now be able to talk
to
the servers on
o five. So we need to give it
some flags.
First one is dash dash insecure dash skip
TLS verify
because who cares about verifying TLS?
And then we need to say minus minus
insecure
dash transport equals false because it is on
HTTPS.
Then we need to tell the endpoints. This
is the HTTP cuddle's got a lot of
flags. So minus minus endpoints,
plural,
equals
yeah. It's HTTPS.
I think you might need to get HTTPS
for the start.
It's not an example there. So I I
kind of omitted it. But Yeah. I think
yeah. I've I've I've just kinda got
Let's see.
And then at the end, we we just
say get
slash.
No. Are we do if we yeah. We'll
we'll try get slash minus minus prefix. I'll
try yeah. Minus minus prefix.
It's minus minus keys only.
This is why I wrote all this down.
We go.
And so that is what that's done is
that's just dumped out everything you ever
like, that's everything SCD knows about in terms
of cluster.
And as you can see, one of the
cool things that's in that list is secrets.
And this is why access to SCD is
so incredibly dangerous
because that's every secret in the cluster.
And are those available
in plain text, or is Kubernetes not providing
any level of encryption there?
The
they are but we're going getting them over
the API. So it's good the by default,
it's in plain text.
You can get the API server to encrypt,
but it's not default.
So guess what? People don't turn things on.
They aren't false.
Very often,
you should turn it on.
But, obviously, if you go via the Kubernetes
API, you'll still get them in plain text.
Right? Because you have to be able to
get them back. But, yeah, we this case
is a default install, so it doesn't encrypt
them by default. So we we can get
them out in plain text. Well, kind of
plain text.
So what we're gonna do is we need
we need our our a token that's gonna
give us, like, access, like, good access.
I'm gonna shout out to one that used
to be really great. There's a there's a
secret. In Kubernetes,
it's the only service account token that you
can get cluster admin without out of the
box, which is the cluster role aggregation controller,
which I bet I had never heard of.
And it used to be there's there's it
used to be cluster admin.
And it's not cluster admin anymore,
but it has impersonate rights so it can
become cluster admin if it wants to be.
We have a complex one to play with,
though.
So what we've got, if you scroll up
a little bit,
I think I put one on here called
admins account.
Yep.
So if you get that path
and then
we yeah. But that just get that, basically.
And this is where we get the the
the light that is
gRPC.
But if you see where it starts e
y? E y j That's j w t.
Right? Yeah. And down to the point where
just for the hash sign.
It's like a hash sign Yeah. So
they are up to e y j. If
you get that and
then
do kubectl
dash dash insecure skip TLS verify because we
don't have the the the TLS setup.
Minus s
HTTPS,
the IP address 6443.
What was the IP address? Sorry. 172
0,
0 5.
It's not 18 or 20. I think it's
143.
Yeah. And then minus minus token
that.
And then, like, get p or something. We'll
get nodes. Yeah.
I mean, just maybe get an IP address
wrong. No. It's not it works.
So that
is literally how you go from
so we we're now we've
now got some access. If you wanna know
how much access we've got, the best my
favorite one of my favorite commands is
auth can I minus manage list?
So we just yeah. Auth can I?
It's the off space can I and then
Off space can I? Yeah. And then that
that's
And
we have the magic at the top, which
is star.star. Star Star.
Anything.
Which is anything. So this is a cluster
admin account,
which just so for for for for ease
of of of doing stuff, this was just
cluster admin because we're trying to demonstrate the
ACD part, not the, like, provest part.
There was also a great quote that Iain
Coldwater did, which I use in all my
talks, which is we're all made of stars,
but your RBAC shouldn't be.
I like that. It's yeah. I love it
because it's it's so true.
There's a lot of
temptation.
Again, Kubernetes is complicated.
RBAC is complicated.
There's a lot of temptation, I think, for
people who really have a problem with it
to just say, give it cluster admin.
I was actually looking at installs for various
open source projects last week, and I noticed
that a lot of them said, if you're
doing this in GKE,
you won't have enough rights to begin with,
so just run this command to make yourself
cluster admin.
And I was like, it didn't ever say
after that, and by the way, remove cluster
admin from your account afterwards.
It just said, make yourself cluster admin.
And I was like, yeah, that's really super
super dangerous
because cluster admin can do anything.
I think every JKE tutorial I've seen, whether
it be installed in Celeb, installed in Rawkode,
any of these things, they all start with,
oh, you have to elevate your privileges. That's
the first thing you have to do with
JK.
And and they always say cluster admin. Don't
say elevate it using this profile that we've
designed to only give you the things you
need.
It's just go get cluster admin.
And And then that rule is just lying
there around forever. Right? It's like a Yeah.
And then someone if someone gets your account
or gets your token,
you're gonna have a bad time. And and
as more and more things go in as
CRDs,
so more and more of, like, people install
things like, say, my Kubernetes cluster is now
good to manage all my databases through an
operator,
you're not just giving them Kubernetes access. You're
giving them database access too to all the
databases you're managing via Kubernetes.
Or even if you're doing OpenShift,
to the machine nodes as well because, like,
machine in OpenShift
now, you're managing the VMs via OpenShift.
So, yeah, that is my one of my
rants about why cluster admin is super dangerous,
but and we see it too often.
Yeah. That makes a lot a lot of
sense, and I'm gonna definitely think twice about
those sneaky little oh, just do this example.
It's it's it's it's yeah. It's super common.
That and the other one I've noticed is
operators. So this is a, like, a QBADM
cluster.
And as I said, there's no one who
gets cluster admin by default.
But to give you an example, an OpenShift
four five cluster, I think, has 42 accounts
that get cluster admin. Oh, wow.
So there's 42 different operators. They're all the
operators. They're all the operator service accounts.
So if this if I was running this
command against an OpenShift cluster, we would have
a load of different choices that we could
use to get cluster admin because I said
because I think it's 40 something. I just
it was over 40 that have cluster admin.
So it's it's it's one I'm kinda hoping
they might fix that, and it's just, like,
early days ago. Because it it
it it's kinda like, you know, in the
old Windows world saying, do people need domain
admin? And the answer is you should never
need domain admin.
You should need you know, so there must
be some smaller quantity of rights we can
you can give people than than that. Yeah.
That makes sense.
So for this one, if you wanna finish
it off, we can just do the exec
command again.
So we can just as we get p
o and then make cube system names Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Okay.
To get the the CSR or mission.
Yeah. Our mission.
They probably want to I think we'll to
get PO first in in KubeSystem to
Yeah.
I was just thinking that.
Was like, oh, I I wouldn't remember that
name. They they are predictable names, but because
kinda's kinda our Kubernetes is good like that.
I
got it.
So that's it. Right? That's yeah. Yep. That's
another another backdoored cluster. Another cluster you can
you can keep access to forever.
Of course, until you delete it in, like,
one minute's time. Cool.
I am learning loads.
Thank you.
No worries. Learning a lot I think what
I like here is I've I've learned a
lot of things that I really need to
start checking on my production clusters. Little subtle
changes. And I think because I use Kubitiam,
I'm probably okay. But it's still nice to
know which things there need to be checked
on a regular basis.
It's yeah. The the the port ones I
said,
for all the mainstream investors, you shouldn't have
a problem.
RBAC rights is a different story.
The
thing that kinda gets me about about RBAC
is
it's so easy for some install programs. It's
like what you said. It's so easy for
some installer to say,
just do this.
And I've seen installers that do things like
give the default service account in the default
namespace cluster admin.
I was like, you might you wouldn't unless
you read the manifest, you'll not notice. Yeah.
And then forevermore,
every single pod that ever gets deployed into
that namespace gets cluster admin,
which is, of course, it's gonna hit you
sooner or later. It's just how long.
Nice. Alright. What what do you wanna do
next? What else is this one? We've done
a lot of server stuff. You said there's
other stuff. Yeah. Let let let's do a
let's do a kind of a a privilege
escalation one. Should
we do to create pods easy? That one's
that one's alright. So SSH to create pods
easy.
What's wrong with create pods hard?
What is wrong with pods hard is harder.
And we we can do pods hard but
we're gonna have to do fun stuff with
like reverse shells and things.
Let's start with easy mode and then if
we have the Yeah. I was gonna say
we'll start with easy and we'll see how
we go on because because pod's hard, it
like it gets a bit harder.
Yeah. I think this is just Like, you
know, there's there's so many here. Right? We're
not gonna do all of these. Yeah. No.
We're not we're not all of them. And
and definitely, if if anyone's, like, watching and
thinking, hey. They haven't covered x.
Issues or PRs
are always extremely
welcome.
Is the automation to build the vulnerable images
all here for people to piggyback on? Yeah.
So the the the images are all in
the if you wanted to create one, it
would just be I would just look at
one of the existing
playbooks. They're all fairly straightforward.
So these are these are manifests where you've
you like, pick, like, the XCD no auth
yeah. These are the tasks.
If you just pick one of the playbooks,
the XCD no auth one or something Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. They they you can be able
see it's not.
So all we really do is say, right,
start up a a kind cluster, and then
we just have a little task to say,
you know, in this, give it a one
you know, I'm gonna do a a custom
client cluster, and I've got a cluster you
see there's a cluster config there? This is
etcd no auth. Mhmm. So what kind lets
you do is it lets you
it lets you customize
how QBADM is installed. So for example, you
can change a port number, you can turn
off authentication, you can change an API server
flag to do something it shouldn't.
And k that's one of the things I
really like about kind is you can just
write these configs. They're a little bit funny
to get used to, but once you're used
to them, they're they're really easy.
Awesome. Yeah. Definitely. I'm gonna play with that.
One of the things I've wanted to do
with, like, the clustered stuff is, like, provide
reproducible ones that people can do and try
and fix on their own time as well.
And maybe doing that through kind with this
config approach would be a a decent way
to do that.
Yeah. For, like, for, like, Kubernetes level stuff,
I think that that would that would work.
Mean, obviously, if you're doing that low level
things kind,
the one place that doesn't shine. But it
it absolutely for for for things like this,
you know, you could you could get clustered
kind of broken clusters quite easily, I think,
for anything like OS level or not.
Yeah. The people that modify the kernel and
the directory and the proxy directory. I I
don't like those people, and I will not
build reproducible versions of that because it's Yeah.
I guess I guess there's I I've always
wanted to do more with, like
you know, because kind is great to a
point, and then for anything like Kubernetes level,
fine. But if you wanna do low level
stuff, I know there's there's good automation for,
like, building raw machines
Yeah. And doing that. You that's what you'd
need to do that, I guess.
So this one's doing a bit more, it
looks like. Yeah. So this one, what this
is doing is is so the idea of
these SSH to something ones is to simulate
an idea that you've got
you're a legitimate user,
and you've got some level of access to
the cluster.
And how and and so it's so it's
it's this a lot of these are basically
things that are in our back. I'm like,
what can I do? So if I've got
create pod, what can I do? If I've
got the ability to read pod logs, what
can I do? You know, all that sort
of thing. And it's how easy would it
be for someone who has that access to
to go and get, you know, cluster admin.
So
what we need to do with this one
I'm gonna get my setup thing up for
this, actually. We need to SSH into
the place that we have the
so it's SSH minus p 32,001,
and it's SSH user
at and then just the IP address.
All one word on the ssh user. No.
I passed the dash l so we should
be okay.
Oh, that's the the user's ssh user all
one word? Not ssh dash user?
Cool. I should do it. And password's the
same.
So
we're now what I've done is I've given
we've given this service account in this pod
a level of access.
If you do,
like, a command, it should it should be
able to talk to the API server.
But you don't have right to get nodes.
You do have right to get pods. I
have some access. Yeah. So you have some
access, but not all the access, which is
if you think about it, that's a it's
more likely to be
what,
you know, somebody who's trying to get extra
access can do.
So if you can see what we've got
here, we've got
right to create pod exec, which is a
subresource of pod, and we can get and
list pod logs,
and then we can get all those new
things to pods. But that's all we can
do. Right? We can't get to nodes. We
can't get to anything else.
So the question is how would we get
access to
to to access the underlying
to the underlying node?
And and so there's no pod security policies
on these clusters,
which means that that, technically, if we can
create pods, we can do bad stuff.
So there's a couple of ways we can
do this,
but let me get the where are we?
The easiest way. So this is the easiest
way. It's kind of a neat one. If
in the in the root of that machine
root of that
pod you're in there, there should be a
manifest called key dumper pod.
I think it's the root directory, if I
remember rightly.
Key dumper pod. There it is. Yeah. So
if we count that out or LSR or
whatever,
what we'll see is
this is just a neat way of demonstrating
if you give someone create pod, what can
they do?
And we'll see what that what that does
is it it's just gonna do like, give
me a pod within BusyBox,
mount the
Etsy Kubernetes PKI directory in, and then just
cap the key. Yep.
So if we create that
that pod on the cluster,
It should.
Fun part is it's going to say oh,
what else do saw? It's say create create
create create initially then.
Once it's done it, I think it'll go
to crash back off loop. We don't actually
care.
There we go. Hey.
And there's your key. Nice and easy.
But if you anyone
so think about it. If you give anyone
create pod on your cluster
and you don't have a PSP
that stops them from mounting host volumes,
there's nothing stopping doing that.
Yeah. Because every worker everything that runs, like,
Kiplit has that
CA key available. Is that right?
Yeah. Well, everything every control plane node. Every
control plane node. Yeah. So the this is
actually a fun one, and I and I
was I was actually discussing on the Kubernetes
Slack today is
what's the security
trade off of running the kubelet on the
control plane nodes?
So kubelet m by default will ship will
run all will run the kubelet on the
control plane nodes, and will run the API
server inside a pod. But it means you
can get to that node through the Kubernetes
API.
And if you can get to the node
through the Kubernetes API,
then you can do this.
And there's obviously, there's tolerant there's tents. People
always taint their control plane nodes, but tents
are not security control. Yeah. They're options.
Yeah. You can just tolerate any taint. So
whenever I'm doing this, I just put tolerate
everything.
Tolerate all the things I don't care about
taint. So anytime anyone
is running their control plane components
in pods,
if you have any users who can create
pods and can mount host volumes,
then that's possible. Is it possible to tell
the kubelet to only run static manifests and
never accept other workloads?
I don't
think so. Good question, though. I I don't
think so. That would be a cool PR.
I'm sure someone Yeah. We get interested. Yeah.
It's
it's kinda like one of those things where
like, if think about it, you need things
like
CNI
and probably logging solutions
Yeah. And everything else.
And it's whether you want to go down
that line of,
like, the the management overhead of of doing
that yourself with, like, system d or wherever
else to run these components on the control
plane. So it's it's one of those areas
where I think there's definitely a trade off.
You know, there's ease of use on the
one hand, and there's, like, you if you
do it this way, you have it depends
on who your user base is. Right? If
you trust all your users or maybe you
deploy everything to your clusters via CICD and
there are no interactive users, this may not
be that bad because you can have a
review process in your CICD pipeline that says,
hey. Post volumes. I don't think so.
I I guess you're probably more likely to
have some sort of a measure controller that
just that wouldn't allow this anyway. Think that
would be like, something like Kivernal running in
your cluster would automatically stop. Yeah. Yeah. Kivernal
and and are
probably gonna be the two ways people will
stop this going forward.
One thing I I kinda noticed though is
you need to be
you need to be whitelisting
acceptable volume types, not blacklisting
unacceptable
volume types.
And the reason is that new volume types
come along.
So you might get something like a new
volume type that comes along and allows you
to do this, like ephemeral volumes or which
are coming along. And ephemeral volumes
so if you say I'm gonna block host
volume, host path volumes, and then ephemeral volumes
come along, if you're using a blacklist and
you don't keep up to date on the
fact that ephemeral volumes just came along,
you won't know that and that may allow
a bypass. Yeah. So, yeah. Tricky.
Yeah. I don't think I like security in
the Kubernetes landscape anymore.
It's it a lot of it comes comes
down to, like, what you're trying to do.
I I've seen
and and there is quite a lot of
push for this at the moment looking at
multitenancy and especially, like, hard multitenancy.
I would be really super hesitant to say
I could do hard multitenancy in the Kubernetes
cluster. I I'm sure that it's possible,
but I'm also sure it's really difficult to
get right,
and you have to be super careful.
Yeah. I I I think I agree. I
guess I I I've never had to worry
about multi 10 say, and I Kubernetes cluster
as well. I I don't feel like I
have any experience there to comment, but, yeah,
I think I'm on your side of the
fence there. Just even thinking about that and
keeping us secure seems like a bit of
a main field.
Well,
you need to get your R back completely
right. You need to get your pod security
policies, what you would have used as it's
going away either the new
I haven't given the name yet, I don't
think. Hierarchical The new replacement.
Well, yeah. I I think something like that
where either hierarchical namespaces or cluster API. If
I was going to try and design a
Kubernetes
multi tenancy thing, I would probably more inclined
to try and do it via cluster API
where you're giving your tenants a cluster each,
not a namespace each.
There is actually a cluster API, a nested
provider, which runs Kubernetes clusters on Kubernetes.
Maybe that's an option people could go for
more hard
multi tenancy.
Yeah. That or or if you can
don't think I actually quite like the idea
of is clusters where the nodes run, like,
Firecracker or something or, you know, some other,
like, serverless style container where there's no real
node to get to. And, actually, a fair
point to make and it's probably worth mentioning
for these is
things like this obviously aren't a problem in
managed Kubernetes because in managed Kubernetes, you have
no access to the control plane. So if
you're running AKS, GKE, EKS, there's no key
to go and get. There are other problems
and there are other things to think about,
but this isn't one of them.
Yeah. Definitely. I do like the firecracker approach
as well. I actually have an episode with
the people that we've worked coming up and
looking at their fire cube project which is
Yeah. Firecracker
I Yeah. But I think that that kind
of the ultimate container runtime approach where I
mean, Docker's great. I love Docker.
But it's it's got what I always call
a flexible security model, and it's flexible. And
if you want to and you have the
access, you can just turn it all off.
You know, privileged containers are a thing. Yes.
You know? So so that's the problem with
flexibility. It's really cool, but it can be
removed if someone has the rights. Yeah.
I think there's there's other run times out
there that are maybe targeting the more security
conscious clusters. Cata containers is the other one
that kinda pops in the head. I think
they're And
gVisor as well. And gVisor. Ones that yeah.
Those are are other ways of achieving. So
things like that, I think, if I was
going to someone said to me, you're engineering
you're
engineering multitenancy clusters, and I wasn't able to
run away, I I would be looking at
at at something like that.
That's cool.
That's the kind of segue in conversation there.
I like that. Yeah. Why don't we we
compromise this one. We got we got the
CA Yeah. That was done. We've we've got
that one. That that that's that's create that
was create pods easy. Alright. How about we
look at one more and then we'll we'll
leave the rest up to the viewers to
try it over time and I'll I'll do
the same and another bit of play. Well,
if you could only pack one more to
first to take a look at what we
see. What do we want to do?
I'd say Tiller. I I was gonna say
Tiller, but not Tiller because no one uses
it anymore. But I I was I was
really talking to an ex colleague of mine.
He said he found it this week. So
Alright. So we're gonna take a look at
Teller, which is the Look at the the
Teller from Helm v two. So this is
now
this is now deprecated.
But, again, as we were saying before, in
large enterprises,
something being deprecated does not mean it will
go away tomorrow.
If you are a a security engineer or
you are a penetration tester and you are
dealing with the enterprise world, you will regularly
come across things that are very old and
have been in there for a long time
because it took two years to get them
installed, and people are not going to uninstall
them just because they're deprecated.
Yeah. And Tethr was so ubiquitous. You know?
I I I can't think of a single
Kubernetes user that wasn't using Helm two Yeah.
A couple of years ago. Like, it was
just everywhere. And for a notable reason, like,
Helm makes a lot of things a lot
easier. Deploying third party applications that you don't
know how to operate.
Helm has a chart for it. But unfortunately,
the teller was this kind of cluster admin
operator
setting in everybody's Kubernetes cluster available to do
bad bidding.
And and for a year, for one glorious
year, it was how
the people in the team and myself compromised
most clusters.
I'm not I'm not even joking. Literally, for
one year,
most Kubernetes security reviews we did ended with,
we are cluster admin because we found Tiller.
That must have been just like your as
soon as you see that, right, you're just
like, okay. This is this is the game
over. Right? The
thing is that Tiller does have authentication,
but the default installed didn't turn it on.
It it warned you. There was a line,
to be fair to them, in the thing
that said don't do this. But if you
hold the the the the getting started thing,
it didn't put authentication on. And as a
result,
we saw I mean, I'm talking production clusters,
not just dev clusters. I'm talking about production
clusters. We found them and they people had
installed it and they hadn't,
you know, turned on authentication.
Yeah. I mean, I think I I've definitely
done the hell install and let Tethr just
do its thing.
It's I I actually wasn't even aware that
I could turn on any Rawkode authentication on
it.
Yeah.
It's
it's one of those things. And I said,
yeah, for one glorious year, that was, like,
you know,
a a not inconsiderable number of clusters that
we would write a report. And it was,
like, critical at the top. You're running Tiller
authentication.
Yeah. We got a a comment from
who
says,
Helm template. A really good way to do
it. The downside is you lose access to
the hooks, but well, not with Helm three,
of course. But with Helm two, you don't
have access to, like, the post install hooks,
the pre install hooks, all those things actually
make the chart work. So, like, 90% of
the time, was cool and it worked, and
I did it as well. But there's always
that chart that it just caused a lot
of problems.
And but a good way to do it.
That was it. And the the yeah. Helm
is great and it it simplifies complex and
sold a lot. But Yes.
I mean, they've changed it now. Right? And
and it's all CRDs. Not not not I
will say that CRDs don't me a little
bit,
mainly because of what I said before about
people giving out star rights.
So you start seeing more and more things
as CRDs.
Things like, for example,
in traditional infosec, you might say read only
rights are sent are safe. Like, saying, oh,
you know, I'll give someone read only. That's
okay. But not in Kubernetes if you start
putting sensitive things
in your cluster.
And a lot of things I've noticed don't
use secrets reliably.
So you can't say give someone read only
to everything bar secrets
because people will put the sensitive thing in
a config map or they'll put it in
a OpenShift deployment config or something like that.
Yeah.
And there's something I've seen is, like, even
though Helm two is now deprecated, most people
are moving away from it, they're moving away
to operators which aren't exactly given much less
permissions than what the teller probably was originally
anyway.
As I as I said, yeah, OpenShift operators
definitely the quantity of cluster admin is high.
It's not I'm sure it's not all of
them, but definitely it's a good number. So
it's it's one to watch if you're going
to operators is what are they doing with
RBAC?
I mean, how much rates are they getting?
And and what does that mean?
Because they're designed to work in most clusters,
which means they're probably overpromised up front. And
if you really want to reign that in,
there's gonna be a lot of, probably,
work to be done there.
Yeah. And I'm surprised when people are designing
operators that that's the approach they're taking because
it it it is complicated.
And as you said, realistically, people want it
to work in as many clusters as possible.
Yep. Definitely.
Alright. We have our new Kubernetes cluster. I'm
assuming there's a teller involved here, so I'm
gonna jump into my client machine. Go back
into client. Yep. And
what we're gonna do here so
oh,
I
should have checked.
So what we're gonna do is we're we're
going to first, we need to find the
teller. So the first thing we need do
is find Tiller.
To do that, we're going to port scan
the
service
port range. So by default,
Kubernetes
has a range of ports that assigns for
services. So if you expose a service or
a node port, it'll say these are the
ports I'm gonna use, and it's 60,000
to 30 to to three two seven six
seven.
And if we do that,
it should there we go. So in this
case, it's gonna be on thirty nine three
four.
So another handy tip if you are security
reviewing a Kubernetes cluster is scan that port
range. So anyone who's put a node port
service into the cluster, it'll turn up there.
Bad node ports. Bad. Bad node port. Yeah.
Bad node ports. But, again,
I I like Convenient. Really convenient.
Yeah. Really convenient. Really handy. And and one
of the the the big things I've found
with Kubernetes clusters is that
people will deploy services inside them thinking that
the network they're on is secure, and so
they don't have to worry about, like, authentication
on that service. So
looking for node ports is always a good
kind of point of attack.
So
now that we've got this,
we can we can try talking to it.
The primary in there is we can use
Helm there's a vendor called Helm two,
which I I I did because there's no
Helm three as well. So I've Helm two
binary,
and we need to tell it where to
go. So it's host
and then 172
well, yeah. It's 1721804.
The port we just got, which was 3935,
I want to say. Instantly forgotten. Oh, it's
30 was it 30935? I think it was
And then version is a good command to
get it to to tell us.
Let me check and see if that's what
it is. 94. Oh, 94. So close.
Still can't type it anyway. Okay. I'm do
that.
And that so that if you find
if you find it, then that's that's a
good way to go. Interestingly, if you're inside
the cluster, so if you're, like, starting from
I'm actually inside the cluster,
you can also get it through DNS
because all services get registered with DNS,
and Tiller is then on a predictable name.
It's like, I think, it's tiller.Kubernetes
no. .Kubernetessystem.service.
You can just dig for that name, and
if that name pops back, you know Tiller's
there. You can always find tiller. There's no
good way of hiding it unless you break
DNS or something.
Damn.
So
we've got that. If we do
l s, so the same command with l
s at the end, it'll Shady Helm chart
here?
There's a there are in so where is
it? It's in
charts.
There is indeed a thing called Priv SSH
chart.
And am I just gonna install it? Yeah.
If you just install that chart, the Priv
SSH chart one.
Name Priv SSH.
It should done. Hey.
So that's now installed essentially a privileged SSH
server
into
the cluster. This is if you phoned Tiller
on a on a
a a cluster, that's that's it. You know?
Because
if he's got no authentication, that's what you
can do. So what we're gonna do is
it's on a port, 31846
there. Not local host. It's 172180431846.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna get that PRS wrong? Oh,
it's minus p. You have to put the
if that's the h, you have to give
it the port as a minus p. Oh,
of course. I
always get that wrong.
Every time. The s h always gets me.
And the the password is really insecure, all
lowercase.
Because I I put this image up on
the
I put this image up there, and I
was like, you know, I I wanna make
really sure people understand this is not something
they should ever use in a real life
situation. So I said, let's make the password
really insecure. Don't do this.
And now we have
a service account instead of a Kubernetes cluster.
Now we're now we're actually on the node.
So we're actually s c h onto the
node. If you you look in the yeah.
So if you look at we're actually on
the the
we haven't got the if you do share
route slash host, actually.
There you go. You're now completely on the
node. That's the whole node. That's the API
server node.
Okay.
So that that SSH is actually running a
It's running a privileged container
with all the host namespaces and everything else.
So that's the full node. That's if that
was a real cluster, you'd be on the
on the a p on the master.
And there's our
Sneaky.
I thought you were just gonna get me
inside of a poet and then maybe do
some sneaky stuff. Yeah. But the fact that
No. A teller could just go ahead and
actually do that. Yeah.
So that's if you think about how that
worked, that was a combination of teller being
there, Tiller being cluster admin, which is the
default,
and no pod security policies.
So
pod security policies would have made that harder
at least,
although, probably, cluster admin could bypass them if
there was any pubs you know, PSPs that
allow it. And it's as it yeah. We
did this is something that I did to
real clusters
because if you have till it was there,
this was possible.
Awesome. That was
very, very cool, but also very, very scary.
Just so many different I get I mean,
the Kubernetes is a large distributed system. There
are just so many different ways for someone
who is
either a hacker or a pen tester or
even just a security advocate.
There's so many different avenues there that you
can just go and knock on a door
and say, hello, are you here? Yeah.
And and and there's new ones coming along,
and this is why, you know, one of
the things you'd always do, and I definitely
still do is each Kubernetes release,
I go and read the release notes.
And I say, what's coming this time? What's
what's new? What's what's changing? And sometimes it's
it's stuff that's hardened stuff down. Now I'll
be going, well, I'll be ticking something off
going, right, that's off my list because that's
been closed. Another time, it'll be, oh, look.
A new feature.
What does that do?
There there was a fun one in in
01/21.
It was already in beta, but now it's
stable,
which is you can use
external
helpers in KubeConfig files.
So if you look at external authentication helper
Oh, I saw that. Yeah. Yeah. If if
someone gives you a kube config file and
you don't trust them, read it because you
can execute any binary off the person's regime
when they run kube kettle. So as soon
as I run kube kettle, it'll just call
that binary and run it. Yeah. They use
that for EKS and JKE authentication. Now it
reaches out to the Google Cloud SDK command
line and the AWS command line to make
sure that you get an SDS token or
whatever.
It it but but there's no, like, validation
of what the binary is. So the binary
can be anything.
So so so the the rule the that
was just a new one for me. Was
like, I will always read every kubectl file
I get before I use it from now
on. Because
if someone wants to be like, to make
a bit fun, they could make it do
all sorts of fun Well, yeah. They could
curl their own endpoint on the Internet, pass
it through your SSH private key or anything
like that. Yeah. Easily. Yeah. Or or or
download a backdoor and run it. You know,
just download a you know, curl something and
and and and run. And away you go
and that's their machine, you're like, oh.
Awesome.
So, yeah.
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to play with
the rest of those scenarios. It was just
Yeah. It's too interesting and too much fun.
So, you know, thank you for guiding me
through the first four or five scenarios that
we did there. Thank for even having that
repository online and making that available to people
to kind of play with.
And I definitely I'm gonna encourage myself and
others to maybe subscribe and watch that repository
and see what new stuff gets added with
each Kubernetes release.
Yeah. And and if anyone's got any ideas,
they wanna see something,
I'm I'm I'm open to issues or PRs.
Yeah. Definitely. I'm gonna check out your kind
tooling for the animal stuff. I think that's
really cool for preparing other scenarios like this
as well. Yeah.
Alright. Well, thank you for joining me. Have
a great day. Congratulations on your new role.
I'm looking forward to us hopefully doing more
stuff like this in the future. And maybe
we'll even get to meet up when there's
no lockdown. I know. Could be a beer
at some point. I hope so, mate. Alright.
Thank you again. Have a wonderful evening, and
I will speak to you soon. Cheers. Bye.
Bye.